in France more violence erupted over the
weekend amid Nationwide protests over
the police shooting of a 17 year old
last week so far more than 3 thousand
people have been arrested around a
thousand buildings damaged and 700
police officers injured the violence
appears to be easy French officials say
fewer people were arrested overnight
than the night before Elaine Cobb
reports from Paris
violent clashes between police and
protesters engulfed France as the riots
continued to spread across the country
over the weekend after the killing of a
French Algerian teenager by police last
Tuesday
in the port city of Marseille protesters
clashed with police
the police in French is racism they
launched fireworks towards the police
tortured vehicles and looted stores the
police responded with tear gas and
attempts to charge down the protesters
45 000 officers were deployed nightly
over the weekend in a Paris suburb
rioters rammed a burning vehicle into
the local mayor's home in the early
hours of Sunday his wife and two young
children had to escape Over the Garden
Wall the funeral of seventeen-year-old
Niall took place on Saturday in nanter
the same Paris suburb where days earlier
he was stopped by police for speeding
video shows the car moving off and a
shot being fired
[Applause]
Niall died at the scene
his grandmother speaking to French TV
appealed for calm they should stop she
urged these people need to calm down
overnight the situation was calmer
across the country with significantly
fewer arrests
president Emmanuel macron meets today
with parliamentary leaders in an effort
to understand how the situation got so
out of control
for CBS mornings Elaine Cobb Paris